salut c'est monsieur green aujourd'hui
je vous parle d'un smartphone de chez un
ami qui s'appelle le ix demi s2 le
smartphone avec une caméra de 16
mégapixels à l'intelligence artificielle
pour les selles fils en tout cas comme
ça que chez l'homme il nous présente
donc trouver dans cette vidéo c'est que
pour va nourrir on a regardé ce qu'elles
ont le ventre on va en profiter pour
aller faire les tests vidéo en extérieur
voir s'il est intéressant voir s'ils se
réunit s2 est cool oui ou non et ça on y
va
bon voilà la bête on va tout de suite le
sourire voilà donc la boîte dur et demi
est donc on va l'ouvrir regardez un peu
comment elle fait
à l'intérieur voir si c'est cool oui non
en loupe délicatement et avec beaucoup
d'amour
voilà donc la bête renmin baisse de 16
mégapixels caméra l'aide selphy light à
l'avant et à l'arrière vous avez une
double caméra 12 mégapixels + 5
mégapixels intelligence difficiel dual
caméras dans la boîte on a comme d'hab
le petit bloc d'alimentation vous avez
ici du micro usb dont 1 usb ici doit
sortir votre tiroir de carsid et de ce
côté là nous avons un petit manuel
d'utilisation et une coque transparente
donc ça c'est plutôt cool voici donc ce
raid me s2 alors on va dans un premier
temps essayé d'enlever ces autocollants
là pour le voir de plus près d'un point
de vue design c'est un grand classique
vous avez un écran de 5 2 99 pouces hd +
forman 1440 par 720 pixels ratio 18/9 ça
fonctionne vous avez une finition métal
brossé à l'arrière plutôt pas mal et
surtout le doublement du photos qui
rappellent forcément l'iphone 10 le
petit capteur d'empreintes digitales qui
est vraiment bien situé pour le trouver
très facilement pour déverrouiller en
plus vous allez pas mettre votre doigt
là dessus donc ça c'est bien pensé un
dos qui est légèrement arrondi plutôt
bien fait des petites finitions ici sur
le côté qui vont souligner un peu ces
lignes ça marche c'est bien fait un
produit qui est pas trop trop lourd il
fait 170 g
il se tient la main dans la main il a un
bon format il est quand même assez grand
vous allez sur le côté votre tiroir
cartes sim cartes micro sd vous pouvez
ranger deux cartes s'initie et une carte
microsd c'est plutôt bien fait on vous
retrouvez votre prise jack ici
d'inforoute pour piloter tous vos
appareils à la maison si vous le
souhaitez de boutons de volume le bouton
on/off ici du micro usb haut parleur
mono et voilà un petit peu pour le tour
ça pareil du point de vue des os vous
avez un android os avec une surcouche
emile 8,9
ça fonctionne c'est pas mal on a les
grands basique à toutes les applis
google vous avez différents outils à
l'intérieur pour trouver votre forum amy
lui votre télécommande infrarouge le
nettoyant fin et pas mal de petites
choses qui sont bien fichu les vidéos le
navigateur dédié en termes de
performance vous avez un qualcomm
snapdragon 625 cadencé à 2
le gigahertz la puce graphique c'est une
qualcomm adreno 506 il est disponible en
deux versions soit 3 giga 32 gigas de
stockage soit 4 gigas de ram et 64 giga
de stockage bon au final en termes de
design il n'est pas une grosse tarte à
tout ce qui existe sur le marché
forcément comme je le dis c'est un
basique mais il reste quand même
séduisant il fonctionne bien il se
débrouille très rapidement un deux trois
j'appuie ça marche directement
j'ai rien à reprocher à l'écran non plus
lcd qui fonctionne bien on est sur un
smartphone d'entrée de gamme il faut pas
non plus attendre d'avoir des
performances complètement wingles sur la
version 3 gigaoctets 32 go de stockage
on trouve à 179,90 euros donc il
vraiment pas cher un produit super
abordable alors ce qui est vraiment
spécifié par shiomi c'est vraiment un
appareil qui est optimisé pour les
selphy avec une caméra 16 mégapixels à
l'avant du point de vue logiciel c'est
vraiment optimisé pour la photographie
en faible luminosité avec la technologie
super pixels qui permet de combiner 4
pixels en un seul donc ce qu'on va faire
c'est qu'on va la tester on va regarder
si effectivement il est intéressant en
termes de photos on va essayer d'aller
voir un petit peu dans les zones sombres
voir si au final le rendu est vraiment
là on était c'est aussi la caméra
arrière voir si les photos les vidéos si
les faits évoqués tout ça et bien on a
aussi un mode de beautiful 4.0 avec de
l'intelligence artificielle par là il ya
pas mal de choses aller voir ça nous a
vraiment vendu comme un bon photophone
pour les selles fille et c'est justement
ce qu'on va les vérifier ensemble
restait le mode beauty faille de
l'acadien ii celle fille vous avez une
petite touche ici là j'appuie et là j'ai
différents mode beauté
donc là j'ai le mode beauté un buzz
goûter 2 est ce que la peau est plus
lisse moins lisse c'est pas hyper
évident à comprendre
dites moi ce que vous en pensez si vous
voyez différence entre un mode beauté
alors je sais qu'il a forcément un coût
de colorimétrie sur ma vidéo tout de
suite mais est ce qu'il ya un écart
quelque chose pour moi c'est vraiment
pas évident je vois vraiment pas le truc
a pris un peu d'avancé qui est là peut
être quelques mois d'avancé et lancé à
ce que je vais plus élancée donc là je
suis lancé à fond parce que les
différences ça ne paraît pas hyper et
vidéos grands yeux c'est léger j'ai
l'impression que c'est un tout petit peu
grandi un peu mes yeux
mais c'est vraiment vraiment très très
doux donc on sera pas forcément content
comme ça bon c'est pas hyper caire
écouter et vachement bitume au filtre de
snapshot et autres qui me font des trucs
de dingue
assis là regardez la taille des yeux
c'est juste les ouvrages et 1,18 g
martial est hyper peur en réalité dont
ça fonctionne c'est très doux donc c'est
pas mal la limite parce que c'est vrai
que le mode multi faille c'est pas des
filtres pour défigurer ça marche pas mal
c'est vraiment très doux c'est pour ça
que ça saute aux yeux dès qu'on le fait
tout de suite je pense qu'il faut des
yeux l'experte là dessus dites moi ce
que vous en pensez
parce que pour moi ça n'a vraiment pas
la tête donc là on est sur le mode photo
vous avez d'autres modes après donc la
mode vidéo cours une vidéo jurés format
classique format selphy puis l'autre
côté bon ça en vaille et est-il si
quelques instants le côté photo avec
comme je voulais montrer le petit icône
là la petite icône pour mini gif le mode
portrait qui est valable uniquement sur
la caméra derrière parce que c'est un
vrai mode portrait avec ici la
possibilité de rajouter différents
filtres c'est pas mal
format carré format panorama et ensuite
un mot avec des réglages manuels vous me
réglez votre balance des blancs rose iso
vous allez après différents paramètres
des rafale la trame de l'appareil photo
4/3 16/9 18/9 escaliers qr codes pas mal
de petits paramètres qui sont quand même
plutôt bien pensé je la mode redresser
c'est peut-être pour la perspective que
ça marche vous avez différentes scènes
portraits paysages sport nuit
pas mal hein ça c'est pas mal pas mal
parce qu'en termes de luminosité
ça va être différent en fonction de ce
que vous allez choo t rex à optimiser je
trouve au niveau de l'appareil photo
plutôt pas mal qualité de l'image très
fine fine normal bon sens l'a déjà vu
que chez différents appareils
des chiens ont mis ça fonctionne
saturation contraste était voilà on ait
réglé un petit peu tout ça alors au
niveau de la vidéo vous pouvez régler
full hd hd standard bien évidemment ici
pas de kafka stabilisation de l'image
d'edith stabilisation un logiciel ici
ouais voilà après c'est relativement
standard mais c'est pas mal de ce que je
vois tout de suite en termes de réglages
ça me paraît quand même assez
intéressant donc lancé un petit test en
vidéo on va regarder si le rendu est
intéressant sur la caméra de cette fille
est alors ici ya forcément beaucoup
d'éclairage à l'ombre au grain pas mal
éclairé on va fêter ça en extérieur on
va regarder la caméra de sélection à se
regarder les caméras arrière on va
regarder le mode portrait voir s'il est
intéressant en ces quelques photos et
que varades et ensuite ça ensemble voir
si ça intéressant oui ou non
bon alors fait une fois la caméra de ses
fils se trouve que le rendu est pas trop
mal voilà me le dire comme ça alors là
et kliment terre de lumière mais
quasiment au mois de juillet donc c'est
super beau un grand ciel bleu beaucoup
beaucoup de soleil et en faire un petit
test tout et les caméra arrière comme à
chacun de justin sur une canne est rien
bien évidemment suivre absolument rien
c'est dans le noir complet pour moi j'ai
souvent aucun retour moniteur on est
choqué son ensemble directement vous
allez me dire vous en commentaire ce que
vous en pensez
est-ce que de ce que vous voyez le rendu
eh bien oui ou non on est à quelques
photos lorsque je regarde un peu les
photos que j'ai prises je trouvais ça va
plutôt pas mal mais mode portrait et
correcte ils ont rendu une bien pâle se
trouve que la qualité est plutôt pas mal
ça va
si vous rendez vous globalement dans
l'ensemble c'est plutôt une bonne brise
part ça y'a rien vrais détails
il ya un vrai détail qui est fait là
dessus sur la photo je dois reconnaître
que vraiment je suis plutôt agréablement
surprise la qualité est là les images
sont assez nette si vous regardez en
mouvement quand même de façon assez
énorme où centre cnet la couleur est
très vrai il ya un vrai détails sur le
côté le rendu vidéo paraît pas mal aussi
je trouve ça assez intéressant c'est
assez bien réussi non je suis à
connaître que l'ap ce point de vue là je
suis vraiment agréablement surpris alors
là maintenant je me retrouve dans une
pièce où je suis quand même relativement
dans le noir j'ai un peu d'éclairage me
travers des des volets fermés de ce côté
là j'ai éteint toutes les lumières est
néanmoins l'appareil continuer à capter
quelque chose d'assez lumineux trouve
que le rendu est pas mal pour voir que
dans la pièce vraiment pas une lumière
là je suis quand même assez bluffé au
niveau du rendu
effectivement après j'ai zoomé dedans je
vais récupérer vachement grain pas non
plus et pour en tout cas de ce cri
annoncé sur la paille c'est à dire un
appareil qui à faire de bonnes photos en
faible luminosité pour moi le résultat
est au rendez vous alors verdict au
niveau de la photo de la vidéo pour moi
je vous le disais c'est vraiment bien
pour voir vous avez une caméra ici de 16
mégapixels avec une ouverture uniquement
de f 2.0
le rendu est cool en faible luminosité
ça fonctionne c'est pas non plus un truc
complètement demain vous allez avoir la
meilleure qualité du marché
une fois de plus pour un appareil à
moins de 200 euros ça fait vraiment bien
la faire niveau autonomie correcte cela
dépend bien évidemment de votre
utilisation
oui vous allez utiliser plus à l'est de
sauvage et plus vives des charges et
vous avez une batterie de 3000 milles et
antérieures ça fait parfaitement bien la
faire pour utilisation standard standard
pour être sauvage sans faire le punk
vous allez pouvoir utiliser une journée
sans aucun problème alors au final
est-ce que ce chien a omis reyniès de
passe le test pour moi oui
pour moi c'est un bon smartphone
d'entrée de gamme à moins de 200 euros
vous serez pas déçu pour tous ceux qui
n'aiment pas les encoches mais pour le
coup il y en a pas pour tous ceux qui
aiment le capteur d'empreintes digitales
également là pour ceux qui aiment les
double caméra la verticale et y en a
également
et pour ceux qui veulent faire des
photos avec un rendu qui est vraiment
correct vous serez pas déçus vous pouvez
y aller les yeux fermés en plus de
chiens ont mis cette fois ci est en
france comme un salissent directement
ses produits pour tous intéressant
d'ailleurs si vous intéresse ce produit
josé lits différents liens dans la
description
dites moi ce que vous en pensez vous est
ce que vous pourriez tenter par un
produit comme celui là est ce que vous
avez déjà des produits chômiste que vous
en avez déjà eu par le passé
est ce que serait mis s2 pourrez vous
tentez vous marquez tout ça est bien
évidemment on en discute ensemble on
reste connectés je vais comme d'hab va
me laisser des jolies pousse à vous
envoyer ce que j'ai parlé toujours plus
de produits de teck innovant toujours
plein de choses à dire plein de
nouveautés pelouse qui vont arriver
d'autres rester connectés et d'ici là
portez vous bien sûr les sages
il vous embrasse tous
[Musique]